the left won't say gun confiscation but
that is what they're talking about we're
gonna talk about what that means what
good gun policy looks like and of course
Jimmy Kimmel gives another emotional
monologue and we'll break it down for
you i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
all righty so we have a lot to get to
today here on the program undergo
through Jimmy Kimmel's monologue last
night that is sailing around the
internet and making all sorts of fuss in
the in the halls of media the Washington
Post said that it was just incredibly
brave the New York Times said that it
was ground shaking we're gonna talk
about what exactly he said what he's
wrong about I'm gonna give you a lot of
gun stats I'm gonna give you a lot of
information on gun violence violence
using guns what the stats actually say
what it means in comparable countries
I'm gonna show you some charts by the
time today's show is over you know a lot
more than you did before about guns
before I do any of that actually I want
to make an apology yesterday I made a
boo-boo on the show I knew it as I was
doing it it was really irritating
because I should have stopped then but
yesterday I said that a semi-automatic
gun can fire burst it can't okay like a
military that has a military rifle that
has the capacity for semi-auto sometimes
also has burst capacity but civilian
guns do not have the capacity at
semi-auto to go burst right every every
single pull of the trigger means a
single firing of the bullet that means
that you're not allowed to fire bursts
from like a normal ar-15 a burst of
three was I got that wrong yesterday I
want to correct myself and I'm wrong I
like to correct myself okay I'm gonna
get to all this information in just a
second but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at blinds.com so
you're looking around your house and
you're thinking what can I do to make my
house look better today well the first
thing you can do is get rid of the
blinds like these ugly blinds right
behind me right you don't need those
blinds what you need is awesome blinds
from blinds.com they make it really easy
for you if you're not sure what you want
or even where to start at blinds calm
you get a free online design
consultation you send them pictures of
your house and they send back custom
recommendations from a professional for
what will work with your color scheme
your furniture specific rooms they'll
send you free samples to make sure that
everything looks as good in person as it
does online and if you miss measure you
pick the wrong color you're an idiot you
mess up blinds.com fixes it for you for
free they will remake your blinds for
free for a limited time you get 20% off
everything at blinds comm when you use
promo code Ben that's blinds comm promo
code Ben for 20% off everything and when
I say everything I mean everything maybe
like the faux wood blinds and the
cellular shades and the roller shades
and more no need for to have these ugly
1980s tiles blinds like I do right
behind me right now go-to blinds comm
instead blinds comm promo code Ben rules
and restrictions do apply go out and
check it out okay so I want to start
with the question why is it the me
whenever they call for gun control they
do it on the heels of a mass shooting
it's really an interesting phenomenon
right I understand why the media cover
mass shootings of course is big news I
mean what happened in Las Vegas over the
weekend was enormous frightening
horrifying news that makes you want to
stay in your house forever and never
come out again and just sit around
thinking about the nature of human evil
because it was that egregious but the
media never talked about gun control
outside the context of a mass shooting
now some of that is just opportunism
some of that is well we think that this
is a good time to talk about it because
everybody's talking about guns right now
but weekend after weekend you'll have
mass numbers of people being shot in
Chicago I know talk about national gun
control so why is it that they always do
it
with regard to mass shootings especially
because mass shootings represent a tiny
tiny minut percentage of the number of
shootings every year in the United
States
according to Mother Jones right you're
seeing the stat that's floating around
right now that's saying things like
three hundred and fifty five mass
shootings this year absolute crap
absolute crap the way that they're
measuring that is if there's any
incident where more than one person was
shot they're considering that a mass
shooting the way that Mother Jones
measures it and Mother Jones a lefty
magazine but they're intellectually
honest about this the way they measure
it is they measure any shooting that has
four or more people who are killed and
also is not a gang shooting and also is
not domestic violence and it's not
robbery so that's how you or I would
tend to think of a mass shooting this is
why when you see these stats about
hundreds of mass shootings you're
thinking no that's not right
because what you're thinking about what
the media are saying are two different
things with that said the number of mass
shootings every year in the United
States is actually quite low so in 2015
mark Fulham and Mother Jones he came up
with four four not 355 four in reality
in the Year 2015 there were 46 deaths in
mass shootings in 2015 how many federal
homicides were there involving guns
almost 13,000 so the number of mass
shooting deaths in 2015 were 0.3 percent
of all gun related homicides in the
United States the same sort of
percentage holds true today so why is it
that we pay so much attention to talking
gun control in the aftermath of a mass
shooting as opposed to say the normal
murder rate well there are a few reasons
one is the normal murder rate has been
going down steadily for the last 20
years so it's hard to make a case
that we need gun control when the murder
rate has been going like this right
murder rate per hundred thousand is down
it is not up in fact the murder rate is
is has been dropping steadily for years
and years and years and the statistics
that you are seeing from from you know
places like voxcom they're ignoring this
box.com did put this data up and they
buried it in one of their stories in
this 7a look at this chart okay the
chart that I'm about to show you is the
rate of firearm homicide deaths in the
United States in 1981 to 2010 you see
how its decline you see how completely
dropped off all right so it's very hard
to make a case that we need stronger gun
control when the crime rate has been
dropping off in the rate of firearm
homicide death has been dropping off as
well
also when you see a lot of statistics
about the rise in firearm deaths they
are conflating two types of death
they're conflating suicide and homicide
so the number of firearm homicides in
the United States has basically been
stagnant for 15 years the number of
suicides however has risen so here's the
chart showing you that the top line here
is the number of firearm suicides the
bottom line is the number of firearm
homicides so when everybody talks about
the number of people being killed with
guns a lot of those people are killing
themselves right a lot of those people
are murdering themselves so to suggest
that this is solely about the number of
murders is just not correct it's just
not accurate now I want to show you one
more chart this one also from voxcom
so this is the rate of firearm suicide
after Australia's gun buyback program so
they use this as proof that getting rid
of firearms can minimize suicide so what
they say is the buyback program begins
in 1996 and you see that the suicide
rates drop all the way to 2006 but I
want you to see what they did here and
look at the period before this look at
the period in 1992 1996 or more
accurately 1987 to 1996 all you see from
1996 to 2006 is basically a continuing
decline in trajectory so this idea that
the suicide rate in Australia was solely
due to the gun confiscation is just not
true again everybody is trying to create
these correlations and then suggests
that taking guns away is causative but
it isn't and if we're going to talk
about suicide rates by country we have
to talk about where suicide rates are
the highest not in
United States in Japan okay so here is a
chart showing you which countries have
really high suicide rates so if you look
at this chart what you'll see is that
the United States is way down there at
the bottom at 10.1 suicides from 100,000
people here are countries that have
higher suicide rates you ready Austria
Belgium Canada Czech Republic Denmark
Finland France Germany Hungary Iceland
Japan right the highest one I guess is
still hungry at 21 Japan has about 20
there are no guns in Japan none okay
they're like six firearm related deaths
in Japan last year but their suicide
rate is nearly double what our suicide
rate is the idea that getting rid of the
guns definitely gets rid of the suicide
is just not true again no correlation
there now I'm not saying that more guns
means less crime I'm not saying that
fewer guns means more crime what I'm
saying is that there is no clear
correlation there is no clear
correlation so I'm going to show you a
couple more stats because I think that
people need to understand this so here
are some stats courtesy of the
Washington Examiner so here is the first
step that your this stat comes from
Mother Jones okay so this stat shows you
this chart shows you the gun ownership
versus gun deaths by state so you see
how there's a line right and this looks
like a pretty smooth correlation right
it looks like gun ownership by versus
gun deaths by state the states with more
guns have more gun deaths right make
sense we're there only one problem
notice the language here gun deaths by
state remember what I just said there is
a correlation in the United States
between gun increase and suicide
increase but there is no correlation
between gun increase and murder increase
so what you're seeing here is a
reflection of the suicide increase how
do I know that because I'm going to show
you right now what it looks like when
you look at the firearms murder rate
okay not the not the not the suicide
rate the murder rate hey this is a
scatter plot of the states in the United
States their gun ownership rate versus
their firearms murder rate from 2014
what you're seeing right now does not
look like a straight line correlation it
doesn't look like any sort of
correlation it looks like a shot gun of
data it looks like there are some states
presumably the the one that's way up
there on the top is probably DC but the
idea here is that there are some states
that have sixty percent don't ownership
rate and very very low rates of firearms
murder and there are some states with
close to zero percent gun
ownership rate and low rates of firearms
murder there are some states right here
in the middle that look a little bit
higher but you know again there is no
correlation at all here and to suggest
that there is is really incorrect and
then finally I will show you one more
chart and that is from again this one is
from the FBI and census related
materials firearms murders per 100,000
residents and I'm gonna and here you see
the District of Columbia is far and away
far and away the the state that has the
most fire armor notice that the states
that have the most firearm murder also
have big cities in them so big cities so
except for New York which has a pretty
low firearms murder rate every area in
the United States 60% of all murder in
the United States happens in I believe
the top 50 metro areas those tend to be
Democrat areas those tend to be urban
areas those are areas that are not what
people think of when they think of
murder rate with high gun root ratios
they think when people think high murder
rate high guns they think you know the
boonies in Texas that's not what all the
murders happening the reason I'm
pointing all this out is because you're
hearing a lot of bad data today you're
hearing a lot of bad data today from
1993 to 2013 the number of guns per
person rose from 0.94 in the United
States to one point four five now fewer
people as a percentage of the population
had guns what that means that a lot of
people like me are buying two guns right
or they're like you and they're buying
five guns but the number of firearms per
person has risen but and the gun
homicides have completely fallen off the
gun homicides have fallen dramatically
so it's important to have all this
information in your head as background
before we start going through all of the
all of the various propaganda that's
being put out that left on this before I
go through more of the propaganda and we
get to Jimmy Kimmel and you break down
what he said about gun violence which i
think is really not just politically
egregious I actually think it's morally
egregious and I'll talk about it in a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over the u.s. concealed
carry Association so I mean right now
obviously you're looking for ways to
protect yourself in cases of violence
and that's why you need the 2017
concealed carry and family defense guide
from the u.s. concealed carry
Association they're giving away a
hundred percent free right now in it
you'll learn how to detect attackers
before they see you they talk in this
book about how to survive a mass
shooting if it's possible the safest and
most dangerous places sit in a
restaurant how to responsibly own and
store a gun even if you
little kids and a whole lot more is 164
pages it comes with a bonus audio
version so you can listen right now in
your car you owe it to yourself to get
yourself this guide defend my family now
calm defend my family now time you get
that guide 100% free instant access you
can listen to it in the car again it's
it's it's invaluable and the u.s. ECA
also has other services like if you have
to shoot somebody now what do you do
when the cops come they help you out
with all of that so you SCC I go to
defend my family now calm again that is
defend my family now calm so okay so we
were talking about why is it that the
media focusing on mass shootings when
mass shootings are such a minority of
shootings so the first reason is because
they believe that they can use the
emotional baggage for mass shootings in
order to promote a particular agenda the
second reason is because the type of gun
and mass shootings differs wildly from
the type of gun that's used in most
homicides so in most homicides what's
used as a handgun right not a rifle in
mass shootings it tends to be a rifle
the left likes to target rifles because
rifles look scarier and fewer people own
them many many many more people own
handguns and own rifles in the United
States and so the left doesn't want to
run right into the teeth of political
unpopularity by suggesting that they can
get rid of all the handguns instead they
like to focus in on the scary ones the
assault rifles right all that kind of
stuff well you can't do that if you look
at the overall murder rate the only way
to do that is by looking at mass
shootings where disproportionately
people use semi-automatic rifles or in
this particular case what looks like a
semi-automatic rifle using a particular
type of stock that that bounces against
your shoulder and makes the gun operate
sort of like an automatic again it's
also worth noting that they like to
cherry-pick so the reason they pick mass
shootings as the as the basis for their
arguments is because the evidence for
gun control is strongest on mass
shootings the reason being the sample
size is really really small the number
of mass shootings generally across the
world is not particularly high so it's
easy to look at something like
Australia's gun confiscation and then
say well before that they had a gun a
mass shooting once every five years and
now they've had none okay but the sample
size is just too small
Australia's gun ban was followed by
elimination of mass shootings the UK has
seen about three since 1980 after its
gun ban but it wasn't like they were
seeing them every week before that
correlation rarely equals causation and
finally the reason the Left likes to
focus on mass shootings as opposed to
homicides is because that's a case where
it's very easy for them to separate the
weapon from the person wielding it mass
shootings are very often carried out by
people who are mentally ill who have
serious problems if the left came to you
and said you need to give up your gun
because gang members are shooting each
other in the inner city you tell you
what no that's the reason for me to keep
my gun right because I'm not a gang
member I want to defend myself if the
left says listen people are mentally ill
you don't know who's mentally ill and
maybe somebody in your family will be
mentally ill give up your gun that's a
stronger case for them the problem is
the vast majority of murders in the
United States or not by mentally ill
people obviously so they want to focus
on situations where it is a mentally ill
person who's carrying out the attack and
therefore it is possible that they can
they can shy it off on society at large
with the availability of guns at large
as opposed to creating a moral status
for the person who's actually using it
so before we get to Jimmy Kimmel and I
really do want to get to Jimmy Kimmel I
first want to show you a couple of
things that people have been talking
about and that probably should be
outlawed they should be outlawed I say
you know if we're gonna talk about
legislation there are a couple of
changes to legislation that I would make
one is there's a while called 18 USC 922
G that is a provision in federal law
that prevents firearms federally
licensed firearms dealers from selling
to mentally ill people one of the things
that needs to be done is Task Forces
needs to be set up in order to
investigate the the crossover between
the number of mentally ill people people
who are registered as mentally ill and
people have gotten guns in California
there's like thirty thousand people in
the state of California who are
registered as mentally ill and still
have guns in their house that's a
problem so that's that's a situation
where we should look into it that is not
a rip by the way on what President Trump
did earlier this year when presidents
from signed a law that suggested that if
you are on Social Security and you're
incapable of handling your own finances
then we should take we shouldn't be able
to take your gun away from you without
due process the key word there is
without due process that's the key
phrase the left ignores that key phrase
that's what the bill did before it was
if they even suspect right if the Social
Security Administration has you
registered as somebody who is using an
aid to help you with finances they come
and take away your gun the bill says no
we actually have to adjudicate that
you're incompetent before we can take
away your gun that's what Trump is doing
there are other ways to strengthen
enforcement of that provision okay other
things that
could be done I don't think those would
be these will be tremendously effective
but I think that it's probably
worthwhile doing so here is here is one
of these things so there's something
called a bump stock okay
this was found on one of the weapons
that was used by the shooter in Las
Vegas a bump stock is basically a
addition that is added to a rifle you
put it on the back of the rifle and it's
essentially a spring so every time you
shoot a rifle the rightful recoils right
every time you take a shot it recoils
well what the bump stock does is it
bounces it absorbs that and then pushes
the gun back and forth bouncing the gun
back and forth you keep your finger
stationary the trigger actually bounces
back and forth on your on your finger so
you're not pulling the trigger like this
a bunch of times right which you can
only shoot as fast as you can pull your
finger instead your finger is stationary
and the bump stock is using the force of
the gun to bounce the gun against the
trigger against your finger that's what
a bump stock is here's what footage of a
bump stock looks like this is what
apparently the shooter in Vegas was
using so as you can see the front of the
gun is moving
right the probably gun is actually
bouncing against the back of the gun on
his shoulder and you can see this guy
has his finger through the trigger guard
and he's just holding his finger there
and then the gun bounces against his
finger so it fires like a fully
automatic weapon if we have outlawed
fully automatic weapons in the United
States it makes no sense to have
addendums to guns additions to guns that
can make them fully automatic so it
makes sense outlaw this the problem is
they are very easy to manufacture as I
explained it very very simple device
right it's basically a spring you put on
the back of the gun that is stationary
and that goes in your shoulder that's it
it's a very easy to make it on like a 3d
printer or something so I'm not sure
it'd be super effective but if we're
talking about legislation to outlaw
things that seems like not a terrible
place to start here's another thing that
I believe they've already outlawed it's
called the auto glove so the auto glove
is apparently a glove that you wear on
your hand and it's used I guess in some
military situations and it is attached
to a battery pack and basically is a
button that goes on your finger and
helps pull the trigger again you'll see
it here's what it looks like introducing
the Auto Club a revolutionary new
product designed to create even more fun
and excitement on the range
designed by military veterans who serve
to protect the freedom we enjoy today
the Auto Club creates an experience like
NOAA now you can experience simulated
automatic rates of fire with all your
semi-automatic pistols rifles and
shotguns
[Music]
your finger goes through the trigger and
then pulls back on it so it essentially
fires at like an automatic that I
believe was outlawed by ATF last year if
not then I believe it was already in the
works that being done now well any of
this stop mass shootings no it's not
gonna stop mass shootings a three out of
the last four mass shootings have been
perpetrated with semi-automatic weapons
but if we already banning automatic
weapons which everyone seems to agree
with including the NRA then these these
particular addendums may not do much but
it seems like it doesn't make a lot of
sense to have addendums to guns that can
simulate the function of a machine gun
okay with all that as background I now
want to talk about Jimmy Kimmel and what
Jimmy come on said last night before I
do that I first want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at five four so right
now if you want to look good it doesn't
need to cost you a fortune and five four
Club is revolutionizing the way men shop
so each month what they do is they send
you a curated box of two to three items
handpicked to match the current season
and your style it's great for people
like me I don't pay any attention to
style I have people who helped me with
that that's why we have like a TV show
right but five for club makes make sure
that I look good when I'm not on the air
they've been helping men with fashion
for 15 years and they shipped to over
100,000 men every single month right now
you get 120 dollars worth of clothes for
just 60 bucks a month that's because
they basically have the same name brand
designers that you would think of just
without the name brand so getting the
same clothes you just don't get the
designer label so you get it a lot less
expensively go to five four club calm
right now enter promo code Ben they'll
give you 50% off your first month's
package plus a free pair of sunglasses a
pretty stellar deal 50% off your first
package at 5-4 Club it spelled F IV e fo
you are club comm and so five four but
spelled out in English five for club
comm promo code Ben again it's five for
club.com promo code Ben there are a lot
of famous people who use this including
me right Chris Paul Mark Wahlberg it's
been featured in places like GQ you can
look good without spending a ton of
money five for club.com and he's that
promo code Ben to get 50 bucks
sorry 50% off your first month's package
plus a free pair of sunglasses okay so
now finally at long last Jimmy Kimmel so
Jimmy Kimmel did something last night
that I find truly abhorrent
Jimmy Kimmel spent an enormous amount of
time last night talking about gun
control it's his prerogative he can do
that but again he makes it about the
emotional appeal and not about the fact
so I just spent the first 20 minutes of
this show explaining to you some facts
and statistics on gun control what it
does what it doesn't do about what
you're seeing when you look at these
statistics what mass shooting statistics
actually look like that's not what
people on the Left do they do a Piers
Morgan does which is they say look at
all the horror just look at the horror
out there we've got to do something
we've got to do it and if you don't
believe me you don't care you just don't
care about those those dead children at
Sandy Hook right this is the routine
that they all like to play it's not just
Kimmel so we'll start with the build-up
right so Kimmel has sort of become the
social justice king of late-night
television and they're a bunch of
competitors they're all trying to
compete with each other to out left
themselves to demonstrate how culturally
relevant they are Trevor Noah leads the
way the least funny man in America
saying that you know the problem in
America is that we just don't talk about
guns which leads me to ask a question is
he deaf or insane we don't talk about
guns in America it's all we talk about
after every shooting here is forever now
what's been particularly heartbreaking
is other than the lives lost is how I
feel like people are becoming more
accustomed to this type of news every
single time I almost know how it's going
to play out we're shocked we're sad
thoughts and prayers and then almost on
cue people are going to come out saying
whatever you do when speaking about the
shootings don't talk about guns we seem
to do everything to avoid talking about
guns
I've never get to a comedy where people
or else has thrown out what he's ever
into a country where people are as
afraid to talk about guns is he out of
his mind has he is he crazy
I mean Democrats have been talking
incessantly about guns for years Barack
Obama gave dozens of speeches about guns
Barack Obama went to Arizona after the
Gabby Giffords shooting and did a speech
about guns he gave a speech where he
cried about guns right we've been
talking about guns for years but Stephen
Colbert does the same thing right he
says well you know the real problem here
is that people just don't have common
sense about guns in order for you to
have common sense about a subject let me
just say something about common sense in
order for you to have common sense about
a subject first you have to know what
the hell you're talking about
hey common sense doesn't just come along
in the wind if you don't know how a gun
operates then you don't get to talk
about common sense gun solutions if you
don't know what gun control looks like
if you don't know what kind of stuff
you're proposing if you're like Hillary
Clinton I've never seen a silencer or a
suppressor and you're saying things like
well a suppressor means that the gun
goes silent you don't know what you're
even talking about that's not common
sense that's just you being dumb because
you don't know what you're saying but
here's Colbert talking about
common-sense gun control presumably as
his studio is guarded by a bunch of very
heavily armed men enough president Trump
you've said you wanted to be a
transformative president who doesn't
care about the way things have always
been done in Washington DC this is your
chance to prove it and I mean this
sincerely you do not owe the Republicans
anything you know the Republicans tried
to stop you from being president well
screw them you want to make America
great again do something the last two
presidents haven't been able to do pass
any kind of common-sense gun control
legislation but the vast majority of
Americans want race because it's do
something to do something but all the
things he says to do have you been tried
and failed or they have been
counterproductive right all the stuff
that the left likes to talk about these
things like universal background checks
in California we have universal
background checks when you buy a gun
from a federally licensed firearm dealer
you have to actually go and get a
background check right they have to this
is under federal law universal
background checks already exist the only
thing that they're talking about and
they say universal background checks are
with regard to hand-to-hand transfers so
I sell you a gun and I'm private gun
owner but there's no real way to
regulate that because if you're giving
me cash and I'm giving you the gun how
do you even prosecute that unless the
gun is then used in a murder there's no
way for the police to even know about it
so that doesn't even make any sense
right gun dealers are heavily regulated
because they're receiving lots of guns
in the gut the government can track it
but if I sell you a gun there's no way
for anybody to know unless you go rob a
bank with it so it's a post facto thing
okay with all that said Jimmy Kimmel
finally goes off last night and Jimmy
Kimmel again has become sort of the all
heart the representative of all leftist
causes so we a couple of weeks ago we
broke down detail his lecture on on
health care reform which was similarly
based not on facts but on emotions
last night he did a long stick about gun
control that was entirely based on
emotion and it was really nasty it was
really nasty I don't know it was nasty
because he doesn't care he cares it's
really nasty because he's suggesting the
you and I don't care it doesn't matter
that you lost sleep last night and I
lost sleep last night because of what
happened it doesn't matter that we're
all heartbroken over what happened we
don't agree with Jimmy Kimmel's evidence
list suggestions about gun control that
means that we don't care we're bad
people you want to know why the country
is not unified it's because it's stuff
like this is not because we disagree on
policy we've been disagreeing about
policy forever it's because there are
certain people in the American public
discourse who feel it necessary to
imputed motives to people who disagree
and that's what Kimmel is doing here so
here's Jimmy Kimmel we're gonna go
through his entire lecture so here he
starts off ripping into Americans who
disagree well hello everyone here we are
again in the aftermath of another
terrible inexplicable shocking and
painful tragedy this time in Las Vegas
which happens to be my hometown and
cletus hometown Cleo seniors hometown
and as you know at least 59 people are
dead
hundreds of people were wounded in what
they say was the deadliest mass shooting
in modern American history coming about
a year and a half after the previous
deadliest mass shooting in modern
American history in Orlando with 49
people lost their lives and of course we
pray for the victims and for their
families and friends and we wonder why
even though there's probably no way to
ever know why a human being would do
something like this to other human
beings or at a concert having fun and
listening to music Jason Aldean was
onstage luke combs who is here with us
tonight he played the show too and
obviously no one could have ever
expected that something terrible would
happen but it did a very sick person
smuggled 17 guns into his hotel room and
smashed off the windows started firing
indiscriminately from the 32nd floor
into a crowd of 22,000 people across the
street and as a result of that this
morning we have children without parents
end
fathers without sons mothers without
daughters we lost two police officers we
lost a nurse from Tennessee
okay so special a room all this is fine
right everything that he's saying here
is true all of it we all feel the same
thing right we're all feeling this okay
he doesn't it's not a matter of him
grasping the emotion and nobody else
getting the emotion we're all feeling
that some of us show it more on the
surface than others but what he is
saying is obviously true but what's
gonna be nasty is when he swivels this
and then he uses it as a club to beat
his political opponents on gun control
which happens momentarily here sure if
from a local school here in Manhattan
Beach and it's a kind of thing that it
makes you want to throw up or give up
it's too much even process all these
devastated families who not to live with
this pain forever because one person
with a violent and insane voice in his
head managed to stockpile a connection
of a collection of high-powered rifles
and use them to shoot people
the guy was an accountant he had no
criminal record his brother who lives in
Florida seems totally shocked genuinely
dumbfounded he said he saw no sign of
any of this the owner of the store that
sold the killer some of the rifles said
he passed the government-mandated
background check when I was in the store
that's it right there for a second he's
giving all the facts
what are these facts he just he passed a
government mandated background check no
history of mental illness
his brother didn't know anything was
wrong with him what exactly would stop
something like this right short of full
gun confiscation which is really what
the left once and we'll talk about the
the possibility of that in a second
short of that which no one on the left
will admit they want but they actually
do want you know they protest every time
you say this if you say the left wants
full-scale gun confiscation Hillary
Clinton I'll tell you know Joe Biden
will tell you no but short of full-scale
gun gun confiscation what exactly would
jimmy kimmel do in a situation like this
he's gonna spell it a bunch of policies
that have nothing to do with what
actually happened in Vegas now wasn't on
any watch list and seem to have been a
religious with political extremists came
out of nowhere and because of that
because there weren't any of the usual
signs you know I've been reading
comments when people say this is
terrible but there's nothing we can do
about it but I disagree with that in
tensley because of course there's
something we can do about it there are a
lot of things we can do about it
well we don't which is interesting
because when someone with a beard
attacks us we tap phones we invoke
travel bans we build walls we take every
possible precaution to make sure it
doesn't happen again
but when an American buys a gun and
kills other Americans then there's
nothing we can do about that okay so so
Charles Koch over at National Review
makes a fantastic points about this
which is Kimmel's now undercutting his
own case right because Kimmel opposes
all those things he opposes travel bans
he opposes walls he opposes phone
tapping I don't assume that he doesn't
care about terrorism I'm sure he does he
just disagrees about the policy so why
can't he grant us the same sort of
credibility we care about what happened
in Vegas we just disagree on the policy
beyond that the fact is that when you're
talking about somebody who's a foreigner
coming into the United States and
murdering people that person does not
have the same rights that you are I do
as American citizens so the sort of
measures that we have available to us to
stop them are different than the sort of
measures available to us to stop
American citizens who are using freedom
in evil ways in order to harm other
people okay Kimmel continues Second
Amendment I guess our forefathers wanted
us to have a k47 is the argument I
assume orlando newtown aurora san
bernardino every one of these shootings
of murder used automatic or
semi-automatic rifles which are not
weapons you use for self-defense their
weapons design okay not true okay so
number one the founders would have
wanted us to have ar-15s because the
fact is that back in the day all the
weapons that people have were
military-grade weapons right a musket
was a military grade weapon now ar-15s
aren't even military grade yesterday as
I said I made the mistake about
comparing basically in m16 which has
burst fire capacity with a civilian with
a civilian
AR right that's not that's not correct I
was wrong about that
civilian guns are very different from
military issue guns for him to say that
the Second Amendment doesn't cover
things like ar-15s a semi-automatic
rifle is akin to me saying that the
First Amendment doesn't cover TV because
the founders had never seen a TV
wouldn't know what it looked like and
don't understand how it works he's just
a silly argument as far as the idea that
they are
are not used for home defense again
asinine and I have a bunch of friends
who yeah who use ARS for home defense
now you can find stories awr hawkins
over a Breitbart has a good good roundup
of people who have used ARS for defense
for self defense it happens on a
relatively frequent basis okay but again
you wouldn't expect Yumi Campbell to
know all of this because here is where
the left's version of common sense means
they have to be completely disconnected
from the fact arch numbers of people in
the shortest possible amount of time
this guy reportedly had ten of them in
his room
apparently legally at least some of them
were there illegally why is that allowed
I don't know why our so-called leaders
continue it allow this to happen or
maybe a better question why do we
continue to let them to allow it to
happen five people got shot in Lawrence
Kansas last night three of them died it
didn't even make a blip because this is
just a regular part of our lives now and
you know it will happen will pray for
Las Vegas some of us will get motivated
some of us won't get motivated though
bills will be written they'll be watered
down they'll fail and our able smother
at all with money and overtime will get
distracted will mow on to the next thing
and then it will happen again and again
and last night what for a second so
again what he's saying here is also not
true and he says the NRA is gonna
smother it money the NRA is not among
the top dozen spenders in the American
political system the NRA does not give a
lot of money to politicians the NRA is a
very powerful force because there are
millions of people who are members
millions of people right the reason the
American people are not willing to to
elect representatives to repeal some of
their Second Amendment rights is because
we're not willing to do that now cuz the
NRA is bribing people it's amazing
Democrats never make this argue about
unions that give tons of cash to
Democrats the unions are bribing people
but they make this argue about the NRA
that is actively not bribing people okay
I want to continue analyzing everything
that Kimmel is saying here but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsor is
over at quip so this is the best
toothbrush on the market it's a company
that's refreshing the way people brush
their teeth so it's an electric
toothbrush that packs premium vibration
and timer features into an ultra slim
design it's half the cost of bulkier
brushes is basically like Apple designed
a toothbrush and you don't have to you
carry around some big restocking set
when you go on the road
instead it's basically the size of a
normal toothbrush except that it
vibrates get your teeth clean and then
you don't get plaque and heart disease
so that's pretty awesome you can
subscribe right now to receive new brush
heads on a dental recommended
three-month plan for just five bucks it
includes free shipping qyp is backed by
leading dentist it was named as one of
Time Magazine's Best Inventions 2016 I
use it every morning and every evening
it is awesome clip starts at just 25
dollars right now go to get quick calm
get quick calm slash Shapiro take your
first refill pack free when you get the
clip electric toothbrush again then just
get quick calm / capiro GE t quip qu IP
comm slash Shapiro your teeth will thank
you your mouth will thank you your
health will thank you again it's get
quip comm / up here I get your first
refill pack free and that's that's
awesome to the ship these the the brush
heads to your house you don't have to
worry about using a brush of it's like
eight months old because you were too
lazy to go to the grocery store okay so
back to Jimmy Kimmel so Kimmel continues
along these lines and you just again all
of this is ignorant none of it is based
on knowledge about guns or firearms or
any of this stuff but this is what
passes for brilliance and common-sense
in Hollywood House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said this is not the time or
actually do was today this morning she
said it was not the time for political
debate and I don't know we have 59
innocent people dead it wasn't their
time either so I think now is the time
for political debate President Trump is
visiting Las Vegas on Wednesday he spoke
this morning said he's praying for those
who lost their lives you know in
February he also signed a bill that made
it easier for people with severe mental
illness to buy guns legally ok this is
not true stop it there ok so again this
is like number line number 8 in this in
this little monologue so number 1 again
this idea that people don't care and
that's why they don't want to talk
policy maybe policy is best talked not
when you are passionate about the issue
but when you're removed a little bit so
that you're not making the sorts of bad
arguments Jimmy Kimmel is making right
here so the bill again that trump signed
back in February did not was backed by
the ACLU it did not in fact make it
easier for mentally ill people to
purchase guns it said that a judge had
to rule you mentally incompetent before
you could have your gun taken away or
your ability to buy a gun taken away
right that's what it says the due
process is still a thing okay you don't
just get to take somebody's gonna way
because you're afraid that they may be
mentally ill you actually have to show
they're mentally ill before you take
Dunaway people who are you know people
in the United States still have rights
until due process goes through okay time
for a few more falsehoods from Jimmy
Kimmel the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell Speaker of the House Paul Ryan
a number of other lawmakers who won't do
anything about this because the NRA has
their balls in a money clip also sent
their thoughts and their posit the idea
that the NRA has has any buddies balls
in the money clip is just not true it is
just not true their constituents don't
want them to do the stuff Jimmy Kimmel
is talking about because the stuff Jimmy
Kimmel is talking about is not correct
okay the NRA is not bribing Paul Ryan
and Mitch McConnell again this is just
him attributing bad motives to these
politicians they don't really believe
what they believe you see they just
don't care enough and they'd rather be
paid the blood money for dead people in
Las Vegas just absurd and now it now
he's getting to the point of insulting
right because now they're all just
weaklings who if they had a shred of
heart they would do exactly what Jimmy
Kimmel answer prayers today which is is
good they should be praying they should
be praying for God to forgive them for
letting the gun lobby lobby run this
country because it is a it's so crazy
right now there are loopholes in the law
that let people avoid background checks
if they buy a gun privately from another
party if they buy gun online or at a gun
show so I want to show you some these
are the truth pause it again this is the
so-called gun show loophole it is not
correct okay the gun show loophole is it
doesn't exist as I said before if you
buy a gun at a gun show from a federally
licensed firearms dealer they must do a
background check if you buy a gun on the
Internet it is shipped to a federally
licensed firearms dealer you do a check
they do a background check before you're
allowed to take possession of the gun
all of this is true the same law is on
the books now that was on the books
fifty years ago if I sell you a gun
there's no way to mandate that I do a
background check because again I have
like one gun and I'm selling it to you
or god forbid I die and I passed my guns
onto my wife right this is hand-to-hand
transfers not the same thing now you can
make the case by the way that we should
force people to do background checks I
suppose I think would be an effective
but you can make the case but it has
nothing to with happened in Vegas
he admitted earlier here that all these
guns were basically legally bought so
again doesn't make any sense it's just
him saying that he feels more than you
feel and therefore he knows more than
you know
based on the Senators who days after the
shooting Orlando voted against the bill
that would have closed those loopholes
these are the 56 senators who didn't
want to do anything about that now 90%
of Democrats I'm not talking about
politicians here I'm talking about
people and 70 77 percent of Republicans
support background checks at gun shows
89 percent of Republicans and Democrats
are in favor of restricting gun
ownership for the mentally ill but not
this gang they voted against both of
those things so with all due respect
your thoughts and your prayers are
insufficient and by the way the House of
Representatives will be voting on a
piece of legislators question who died
and made Jimmy Kimmel God who's Jimmy
Kimmel to decide whether their thoughts
your thoughts and your prayers are
insufficient so your thoughts in your
prayers are only sufficient if you do at
Jimmy Kimmel wants you to do that's the
way this works now who died made him
Jesus like really how did this work
exactly the Jimmy Kimmel gets to be the
great moral arbiter of our time a late
night talk show host who used to host
the man show with women bouncing on
trampolines he's now the great arbiter
of what constitutes morality and
politics and if you disagree with him
your thoughts and prayers are
insufficient it doesn't matter that you
were fervently praying for the victims
doesn't matter that you were donating
your time of your blood none of that
matters if you disagree with Jimmy
Kimmel what you've done today is
insufficient you must pay you will burn
in the fiery bowels of Jimmy Kimmel's
hell just gross this is just gross stuff
okay again I'm not doubting Jimmy Kimmel
sincerity I believe he is completely
sincere I'm doubting whether it is moral
to down other people's sincerity based
on their political viewpoint he
continues we it's a bill to legalize the
sale of of silencers for guns isn't what
they're working on we have a major
problem with gun violence in this
country and I guess they don't care and
if I'm wrong on that fine do something
about it because I'm sick of it and you
know I was a comment on your gang he's
sick of it so I guess we're done here
gang I mean as long as he's sick of it I
guess that those rights just go out the
window again he's bring up silencers and
suppressors stupid okay there there is
no silencer or suppressor used in this
crime and if you use a suppressor which
is what what people who don't know
they're talking about call a silencer
yeah I mean the opposite if you're a
sight if you use a silencer which is
what a suppressor is
all it does is it reduces the the sound
from basically a gunshot to a jackhammer
so it's still incredibly loud again none
of this has to do with anything that
just happened in Vegas but Jimmy
Kimmel's on a roll now you know bluto's
going don't don't let's stop him now
just let him let him let him roll again
this is he's sick of it he's sick of and
then he says and then he talks about how
he really wants to do comedy but he
can't because he just feels too much
sure I hate talking about stuff like
this I just want to you know laugh about
things every night but that it seems to
becoming increasingly difficult lately
it feels like someone has opened up a
window into hell and what I'm talking
about tonight isn't about gun control
it's about common sense common sense
says no good will ever come from
allowing a person to have weapons that
can take down 527 Americans at a concert
okay pause it right there I know some
good that can come from those people
having weapons how about the cops you
broke down the door so this guy killed
himself they all had these kinds of
weapons all of them so clearly some
people should have these weapons it's
just not you
right that's what Kimmel is saying and
he goes on and we don't have to do the
rest of it but basically he suggests in
the transcript he says the NRA fought to
make sure the people on the no-fly list
can buy guns again Teddy Kennedy was on
the no-fly list the problem with no-fly
no-buy is that the no-fly list was too
broad and again there is something
called due process of law in the United
States he says that no American citizen
needs an m16 or ten of them okay
military-grade weaponry is largely
illegal for private citizens to own in
the United States we're talking about
something with automatic capacity
machine guns have been banned in the
United States since 1986 any machine gun
made after 1986 you'd illegal for you to
own under federal law and then he says
you should write your congressperson and
you should do something and then he says
he thinks it's important and he finishes
by saying you know I think it's
important okay well guess what we all
think it's important we all think it's
important but you are not an expert just
because you feel deeply you feeling
deeply does not make you an expert on a
topic it does not give you the
background expertise it's not give you
the statistical expertise to talk about
this stuff even people who study this
stuff make statistical mistakes I made
one earlier today when I have tweeted
something out and corrected it
the fact is Jimmy Kimmel doesn't even
bother with that kind of reach
and the media are cheering him why
because all that matters is the feelings
we can't have a healthy body politic
like this we cannot we cannot have a
healthy body politic when the suggestion
is that people on the other side just
don't give a crap about their fellow
Americans being shot and murdered in
cold blood they're just being paid off
by the NRA that's a recipe for people
out in the streets hitting each other
with clubs that really is this is a
disaster area substituting emotion and
emotional accusations for discourse that
is reason that evidence-based is a huge
mistake Jimmy Kimmel should not be
cheered for what he did last night Jimmy
Kimmel should be asked to provide the
evidence for his sub positions rather
than the evidence for his emotions again
I believe he's sincere sincerity does
not make what you're saying smart okay
so Democrats were pushing along these
same lines and they are all basically
following Jimmy Kimmel's lead now so
we'll have more of this tomorrow but
first you know I want to do things I
like and things I hate we'll do that but
first you have to go over to Daily wire
calm and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
can get a subscription to daily wire
calm you get the rest of my show live
you get the rest of the Andrew Clavin
show live you get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live you can get them all
later by downloading them at iTunes or
SoundCloud you get them on video live
when you go over to daily wire calm also
you can get the full episodes when you
go to daily wire calm on video which is
great when I show charts you know what
the hell I'm talking about plus you get
to be part of our mail bags on - on
Friday I believe that Clavin does his on
Wednesdays you get to be part of the
mail bags and when we do our special Q&A
is you get to ask questions there as
well if you just want to get the feeling
at the annual subscription which saves
you 20 bucks off the off the monthly
price you can get the annual
subscription for 99 bucks you get the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblr which
is enjoyable mug from which to sip
leftist tears as the name would suggest
so go over and check it out right now
it's daily why otherwise go to YouTube
SoundCloud iTunes please subscribe leave
us a review particularly over at YouTube
where we post a lot more stuff than just
the show you want to check us out over
there and subscribe we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
you
okay so a couple of things that I was a
couple of things that I like here so
first thing that I like sometimes you
just need a break from the news
obviously and a book that I've been
reading enjoying a bedtime I book called
the game inside the secrets of
baseball's power brokers by John Pesa I
believe he wrote for a Sports
Illustrated and it's a it traces
basically how baseball was shaped from
1993 to 2010 by Bud Selig and the owners
and the players union it's really fun to
read it's really comprehensive if you
like baseball you'll like the book check
it out the game by John Pesa okay other
things that I like so in a time when
we're tearing each other apart at a time
when we are suggesting that we don't
care enough about each other I want to
show you this video this happened about
one hour before the shooting in Las
Vegas this is what the concert looked
like an hour beforehand with when when
everybody was singing god Bless America
together again this is one hour before
the massacre in Vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
you know that's that's that's America
that's America it's it's people like me
and Jimmy Kimmel we disagree at
everything but we get together and we
sing god Bless America because we agree
that we're brothers at the end of the
day I may be ripping Jimmy Kimmel today
because I don't like his implication
that people like me don't care enough
but I care what happens to Jimmy Kimmel
I think Jimmy Kimmel cares what happens
to me I think that we both care what
happens to Americans when bad things
happen and even if we disagree on the
policy we can still agree that we care
for one another enough to live in a free
country
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate okay so yesterday the ESPN reversed
its decision not to show people standing
or kneeling for the anthem they had said
for about a year they weren't gonna show
the anthem last night they reversed
themselves because they felt like in the
aftermath of the shooting they should
show people standing for the anthem
anthem is a sign of unity one NFL player
actually sat during the anthem anyway
after the shooting which is just
incredible the player of course was was
a cornerback named Marcus Peters and a
linebacker named Oki Mela gray I guess
the only two players on either team who
decided to sit during the anthem here's
some video here's Marcus Peterson during
the anthem
[Music]
okay it's at times like this when you
see that and you realize look the
national anthem still is a unifying
force god Bless America these symbols of
unity mattered dammit they do matter
okay I think that Marcus Peters probably
wants American unity too but he needs to
understand the one he ripped symbols of
American unity all he is doing is
tearing us apart further we need these
symbols we need them they are important
symbolism matters in every religion in
every political race in every in every
political in every Republic symbols
matter we have to hold something
together or we're going to be separated
and that's not gonna be good okay one
more thing that I hate there's an actor
who tweeted something stupid yesterday
he tweeted there's this ridiculous
notion from a lot of people now that
they should be tweeting things their
children say it annoys me so this actor
I guess the name is Boris Kodjoe he's on
some TV show or another he says my 10
year old asked me how the shooter was
able to get his machine gun I told him
that pretty much anyone in the US can
but why daddy he asked okay so so many
things are wrong with this first of all
you know whenever people say my kid
asked me usually their kid didn't ask
them but beyond that let's assume that's
right why are you lying your kid not
anyone in the United States can get a
machine gun not only won the United
States can get a machine gun that's
absolute nonsense again it's been
federally illegal to get in a post 1986
machine gun in the United States since
1986 it's just not the case again
emotion overcoming rationality and
overcoming evidence is the death of
political discourse okay so it's been a
dark day it's been a very dark week
hopefully tomorrow will be a better day
and and we'll show you all sorts of fun
things including President Trump
throwing paper towels at people I guess
in Puerto Rico like that's a thing that
actually happened
we sorta ran out of time today but I'll
show it to you tomorrow in the meantime
keep safe out there and know that your
neighbor loves you even if you guys
disagree on politics okay we talk about
every day about the disagreements let's
talk a little bit about the love your
neighbor you know they may not like you
but they love you because we're still
all Americans I will see you tomorrow
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]